it what do you got there nate this is  the corn dog from  the food truck world's best corn dogs  wow  and who is that for for john langler  who says he's never had a corn  mustard is recommended  this is such a call back  all right  we have the mustard  world's best corn dogs what's the name  of the world best corn dog is it just  called literally called world's best  corn dog yeah okay  i can't scrub this  but let's not spill on my white shirt  here kids  good luck  hope it's not too hot  for innovation for inspiration of course  do you not like it  we're watching  painted bread  wrong you're supposed to talk  why  he's never had a corn dog before he  doesn't know i'm being ridiculed for my  corn dog are we about to go by the  protocol hang on we got to get out of  the way for so sure i can do the weather  there you go but mother anything is good  there you go  [Music]  so  you